RAHUL MEHENDALE: Hello, my
name is Rahul Mehendale,
and I lead New Business Creation
within Deloitte's life sciences
and health practice.
With me is my colleague
Jurgen Planck,
who is our precision
medicine leader.
We are here today to examine the
future of biomedical research.
We are going to look both at
how biomedical research has been
conducted to date and how
the landscape is changing,
as well as a potential solution
that we are using to address
this innovative field.
Biomedical research is
at a unique juncture.
It is increasingly
turning to data science
to make new discoveries
for treatments.
Let me give you three
examples of drivers
that are causing this
change and the resulting
needs for data science.
First, there are
large volumes of data
now available, orders of
magnitude more than before,
that need to be stored
for efficient use.
This includes the traditional
sets of science-generated data,
such as genomics data,
imaging data, clinical data--
but also patient-generated
data from variables,
and environmental data
and exposure data.
These data are now
being collected
in ever-increasing quantities,
and that is an expectation
that if they can be easily
stored and analyzed,
they can help drive new
discoveries and treatment
options.
Thus, there is a huge need for
storage and efficient search
capabilities for
biomedical data.
Second there is an
interest in driving
deeper into precision
medicine by using
artificial intelligence.
Researchers want to understand
how the body functions
at all levels--
starting at the molecular level,
then at the cellular level
and the organ level.
Take cystic fibrosis
as an example.
Researchers found a correlation
between the CFTR gene
and the disease, leading
to the understanding
that a mutation in
the CFTR gene was
the cause of cystic fibrosis.
From this discovery, a new
treatment could be developed.
And two years ago, the FDA
granted a breakthrough therapy
designation to a particular
gene therapy that
addressed the mutated gene.
However, in most
cases, the relation
between genetic mutation and
disease is much more complex.
It is not a one mutated gene
causes one disease situation.
So researchers
need to go further.
They need to understand
how the body functions
at the molecular level,
looking at all genes
and proteins in action
within cells and organs.
This will require
the development
of new artificial intelligence
methods that can analyze
all of the data available.
Thus, biomedical
research is becoming
a huge computational task.
Third, there are an estimated
7,000 rare diseases,
of which only 500 have
treatments-- and even fewer
have cures.
Thus, there is an urgent
call to researchers
to share all of their data.
The rapidly advanced the
discovery of new treatments.
While each of these
7,000 diseases
may be rare individually,
the total tally
affects a significant number
across the population.
Do note-- be learned that
cancer is not just one disease,
but rather, it is a collection
of many different types
of cancer, some of
which are very rare.
We need to understand
what is happening
to the body of each of
these different cancer types
in order to find cures.
By sharing their data with
the research community,
there is an opportunity
to perform new analysis
and make new discoveries.
Let me summarize-- to
make new discoveries
and find new treatments,
biomedical researchers
will need to be able to
store analyze, and share
all of their data at scale.
We are now going to look at
a particular use case that
focuses on the necessary
steps to share data
without compromising privacy.
The biomedical data
we use for research
are collected from humans.
And ensuring the privacy of
these data donors is critical.
Without it, we would put at risk
the trust given to scientists
by these data donors.
The HIPAA privacy rule
establishes the conditions
under which protected health
information or PHI maybe
used or disclosed for
research purposes.
In short, HIPAA requires
that all PHI be identified
before data are shared.
In addition, other laws
require that all personally
identifiable information
PII also be de-identified.
Our use case focuses on the
identification of imaging data
for cancer, cardiovascular,
and pulmonary research--
a critical step
before these images
can be shared that the
research community.
On this slide, you will
see a pair of lung x-rays.
Today, most CT scans,
MRIs, and x-rays
use the DICOM standard, which
stands for digital imaging
and communications in medicine.
DICOM data has a header, which
includes PHI and PII data.
See the red boxes on
the top left and right.
In addition, the PHI and PII can
be found on the image itself.
See the red box at the bottom.
We are working with
our client on a pilot
to ensure that patients' data
is de-identified by removing
masking or encrypting the
sensitive PHI PII data
before images are shared.
To do this, we are using
Google's health care API
as an out of the box solution.
In our pilot, we are working
to answer two questions.
How reliable is the
de-identification process?
And what is achievable
throughput of the process?
This is important as we are
working to do this at scale.
As you can see, de-identifying
data just from images
is a large undertaking.
And this is only
one of many steps
that must be taken to prepare
data for large scale analytic
efforts.
If we take a step back and
look at all the steps required
for biomedical research, we
realize that what we need
is an efficient
solution that provides
the biomedical community with
the ability to store, analyze,
and share their data at scale.
We will now discuss how we can
build such an environment that
meets these needs on the
Google Cloud platform.
However, we should note that
a technical solution alone
will not be sufficient
to create a timing
ecosystem of biomedical research
that widely shares their data.
There are several
non-technical challenges
that must be overcome, but
they are beyond the scope
of this presentation.
I'm now going to
hand over to Juergen
to walk us through the details
of the GCP-based solution.
JUERGEN KLENK: Thanks, Rahul.
To start, let's
examine the principles
of a biomedical research
data science solution.
As Rahul mentioned,
there are three
key functional requirements--
the ability to effectively
store and manage data,
the ability to
analyze data at scale,
and the ability to share
data with the community
and effectively
use to share data.
Let's look at each
of these three
in turn, starting with
data organization.
A foundational principle for
organizing by medical data
is the concept of FAIR data.
Fair stands for findable,
accessible, interoperable,
and reusable.
Let's look at what each of
these mean, F for findable,
A for accessible, I
for interoperable,
and R for reusable,
starting with findable.
This means that all data must
be annotated with metadata
that makes the data searchable.
This must be possible
for all data types,
the data should be
stored in a data lake.
And we need a proper
metadata repository.
Data that is newly
ingested should ideally
be annotated with metadata in an
automated or semi-automated way
to allow data ingest at scale.
Finally, we need an
efficient search mechanism
that lets us discover
data of interest.
This must be possible
for all data.
Today, most data sit in silos
that cannot be searched from
the outside.
The next one is
A for accessible.
This means that there
must be an easy way
to request access to data that
has been discovered and is
of interest.
Ideally, we don't want
to move the data around,
so data access
really means that I
can use the data
to compute on it,
and quite possibly,
compute across many data
sets that may reside
in different locations.
What we have today,
again, is still mostly
data silos, where it is
impossible to run algorithms
across the data sets.
The third fair data concept
is I for interoperable.
Now this is where data
standards come into play.
Unfortunately, in
biomedical research,
there is a myriad of standards.
At a minimum, data should
adhere to a common standard,
and we need mappings between
the most common standards.
And yes, by data
standards, I also
mean semantic standards such as
ontology and vocabularies, not
just syntactic standards.
I is probably the hardest
of the four fair principles.
Finally, R for reusable.
This has to do with data use
agreements and consents that
accompany the data.
It must be possible to trace
what data are used for so
that any misuse
can be discovered
in appropriate measures
to protect the data
and their human data
donors can be taken.
When it comes to the second
requirement, powerful data
analysis, we have to realize
that algorithms are actually
just data, as well.
And thus, their code should
also follow fair principles,
because in the end, we not only
want to share the raw data,
but also, our analysis
methods in order
to accelerate innovation.
We need an easy-to-use
data science environment
that allows us to scalable
compute across all
of the data of interests.
Furthermore, we want to
be able to reuse already
existing algorithms.
Many of these are
encoded in the form
of services that are natively
available on the Google Cloud
platform.
The previously discussed the
de-identification service
is such an algorithm.
And we need to be able to
access it programmatically
through its API in an easy way.
Many other algorithms are
bundled into libraries.
This could be machine learning
and artificial intelligence
methods for image analysis
or for a genomic study.
Again, these
algorithms or libraries
must be easily accessible
from within the data science
environment.
The last requirement
is data sharing.
We already discussed this as
part of the FAIR principles.
But to reiterate,
sharing must be possible
not only within teams, but
also, across teams and even
between institutions.
If we follow these
guiding principles
when building a solution on
the Google Cloud platform,
we will have enabled the
biomedical research community
to focus on what
they are best at--
doing their research
without having
to worry about the
underlying technology.
And hopefully, be able
to accelerate discoveries
and new treatment options for
the many untreatable diseases
that ail us.
We have developed a CGP-native
reference implementation
for biomedical research solution
that follows the principles we
just discussed.
You can see some
screenshots on the right.
And I will show an
architectural diagram later on.
The data types we have to
handle include clinical data
in the form of electronic
health records,
often now following the
FHIR standard, genomic data,
medical and scientific
imaging data, radiology images
following the DICOM standard.
Pathology images
do not consistently
follow that standard.
And we have also handled medical
supply chain and public health
data labs, mostly
as part of our work
for the COVID-19 health
care coalition, which
is a pro bono effort of almost
1,000 organizations coming
together to share
data and perform
studies to combat COVID-19.
We're also supporting a
variety of analytic methods.
Researchers often prefer to
use a notebook-like environment
to coat their methods and
workflows, specifically
Jupyter Notebooks that can
be coded in R or in Python.
To select data sets
and those cohorts,
but also to generate
downstream analysis,
BigQuery can be easily used.
We also discussed access to
micro services via their APIs
the Google Cloud platform
through its many health
care and biomedical
products, offers
access to many services
ranging from genomic analysis
to data mapping
to image analytics
to advanced machine learning
and artificial intelligence
and more.
These are powerful
tools that we can bring
to the researchers' fingertips.
And finally, we
offer the ability
to reuse existing workflows
through sharing, enabling
true collaboration in method
and algorithm development.
Now let's take a closer
look at the solution.
You can see here
two screenshots.
The left screenshot
shows the home screen,
where you can see all
of your projects listed.
Projects are the big
tiles on the screen, which
show the project name,
a short description,
and the approved users.
Of the right screenshow,
we open one project.
At the top, you can see the
project information again.
On the left is the
metadata repository,
which is searchable, and where
it can select data for use
as well as share
data with others.
And on the right side
are the workspaces,
where it can launch Jupyter
Notebooks to perform
your analyses.
What's important is that this
user interface is intuitive
and takes away from the
complexity of the Google Cloud
Platform itself.
If I showed the GCP home screen
to a biomedical researcher,
they would be overwhelmed
by the choices of tools
and often not understand
how to use them.
Our user interface provides
them with an intuitive screen
that they can understand how to
navigate and perform that work
all the while using the
full power of GCP behind it.
Let's take a look
at the architecture.
I'll start on the
left side, this
is where we receive data from
systems such as microscopes
or other devices that can
stream their data right
into our environment.
We can use a command
line interface
to push the data with
a defined frequency,
or we can manually
load the data.
The ingest process uses cloud
network and Cloud Data Fusion
to push the data into a
Google Cloud Storage bucket.
The metadata repository near
the middle of this slide
serves as an environment to
store all metadata associated
with the collected data.
Upon data ingest, data can
be inspected for tags--
for example, FIHR
or DICOM tags that
can be used to automatically
generate metadata.
We use services provided by
the Google health care API
to the left of the
metadata repository
to perform initial
transformations of the data
such as de-identification.
This requires
temporary placement
of the data into a
FIHR or DICOM store
where the data identification
service is being performed.
We have a data sharing
capability that invokes
[INAUDIBLE],, Firebase,
and can leverage services,
such as Google's
data marketplace
to make data discoverable.
For search, near the top of
the slide, we use Apache solar.
And to the right, we have
notebook services that utilize
GCP's1 JupyterLab to
launch notebook services.
In these notebooks all
the way on the right,
in the second box from
the top, the researchers
can code and execute
their algorithms.
They can also
access GCP services
through what we call convenience
methods, which are wrappers
around the API is so that
researchers don't have to learn
the detailed command syntax
of an API call, but instead,
can use a very simple
and intuitive command
such as de-identify with
some simple arguments.
For security, we use the
native GCP security layer,
which provides identity
and access management
and offers a very granular
roll-based data access.
Cost management is
also built in to1
allow researchers to see
the cost of the service
before they use it.
Above all, we strive to follow
the open community's best
practices.
Data will not end up
in a proprietary silo.
Rather, it sits in a GCS bucket
and can be accessed and reused
from any other environment.
Similarly, Compute uses
native GCP components,
which will work across
data sets stored in GCS.
What we hope to illustrate with
this reference implementation
is to demonstrate
how we can stop
building more proprietary data
silos in biomedical research
that will just prevent the
community from collaborating
efficiently.
If we follow the standards and
best practices we laid out,
solutions like our
reference implementation
will enable the construction
of a collaborative biomedical
research environment that can
help researchers accelerate
discoveries and treatment.
Now I'll hand it back to Rahul
to close out our discussion.
RAHUL MEHENDALE: Thanks,
Juergen. And thanks,
Google, for the opportunity
for this discussion today.
In summary, we have reviewed
how biomedical research
is transforming
into a data science.
We discussed the principles
of how biomedical data can
be effectively
managed and analyzed
in the Google Cloud platform.
And we showed you a
reference implementation.
In addition, we discussed
how Google Cloud platform
allows us to do
biomedical research
in a highly scalable
and cost-effective way
in the cloud.
And finally and
most importantly,
a cloud-native solution
for researchers
to collaborate and share
their data with one another
is widely important to
accelerate scientific discovery
and find new treatments for
the many still untreatable
diseases.
If you have any questions
on this presentation
or the content, please feel free
to reach out to us directly.
We have included our contact
information on this slide.
Thanks again for your
time and interest.